one guy who didn't win
at least hasn't won so far in his nfl
career jadavian clowney this is the
prime example of the downside of the
rookie wage scale it was put in place to
ensure that busts don't suck millions
out of the system without earning it so
the guys who do earn it
don't get paid what they would have
gotten paid jd and clowney if he'd have
been the first overall pick four years
earlier than he was in 2014 he would
have gotten so much more money than he
received but he still hasn't gotten a
second contract and you've got the
texans playing games with him and not
that there's i look i
they have every right to do it
they are allowed to squat on him for the
five years of his rookie contract
they're allowed under the cba to
franchise tag him once or twice or even
three times if they want to and then he
becomes a free agent at some point down
the road when his value is far less than
what it would have been they're allowed
to do that the one thing that kind of
put me over the edge though the games
they're playing with the franchise tag
designation of judaevian clowney and now
a grievance rightfully has been filed
over whether or not he's defensive end
or a linebacker we're only talking about
a million and a half dollars and i know
that's a lot of money
in isolation but but still for a guy who
has been a loyal and faithful employee
of the franchise who hasn't been
clamoring for a new contract publicly
who hasn't held out hasn't even thought
about holding out when he was under
contract and currently he's not under
contract i i i don't know why you do
this to the guy and at some point you
have to wonder
what impact does it have on the locker
room somebody asked me that question
yesterday as it relates to clowney not
getting a long-term deal
and my reaction was well you know in the
eyes of the locker room i think it's
worse to have an undrafted guy like aj
bouier that puts in four years does all
the right things and has to go somewhere
else to get paid like he had to go to
jacksonville to get paid
with clowney the other guys in the
locker room say hey he was the first
overall pick in the draft he's made a
hell of a lot more money than us and i
don't think that there is as sensitive
to the niceties of how it used to be
when a guy would really get big money to
be the first overall pick
but when there's a perception you're
screwing around with the guy when you're
nickel and dimming him and again i know
a million and a half dollars is a lot of
money in isolation but when you're
talking about 190 million salary cap
when you're talking about a guy who has
been part of the team all these years
i just
i wonder at what point it it
it becomes
a factor
among the players and i wonder how much
hand-holding and sweet talking jack
easterby's gonna have to do in the
locker room if players are pissed off
about the way that they're handling
jadavian clowny it's a very simple
analysis you're either a linebacker or a
defensive end based upon where you lined
up for the majority of the snaps
during a given year now it gets
complicated because linebackers in a 3-4
often end up with a hand in the dirt
rushing the passer but you know we we
saw this with jimmy graham several years
ago graham lost that argument whether he
was a receiver versus a tight end we're
going to see it again now would you
davey and clowny we shouldn't have to
the texans should just do the right
thing and pay this guy as a defensive
end and move forward or better yet give
him a long-term contract the long-term
contract that he earned
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports